I spent 22 incredible years at Apple,
helping to design experiences and devices
ranging from the Mac
to the iPhone to the Apple Watch.
And as the power of compute increased,
the size of our computers
or our devices decreased.
The desktop paved the way
for extraordinary interconnectedness,
but it was stuck to your desk.
The laptop provided portability,
but you still had to be
sitting down to use it.
And the smartphone evolved us
into the modern, connected humans we are,
providing millions the ability to access
the internet from our pockets.
And the smart watch
was a window to that phone.
A companion device
with a whole host of health insights,
all shrunk down to your wrist.
But what comes next?
Some believe AR/VR glasses
like these are the answer,
but they merely move the screens
we already have in our lives today
to being just millimeters
away from our eyeballs.
A further barrier
between you and the world.
And the future is not on your face.
In fact, in 2017,
the legendary tech journalist
Walt Mossberg wrote in his final column
that he felt that soon, one day,
technology would become invisible.
And that the computer would disappear.
And we agree.
(Ringing)
Sorry.
This is my wife.
I'm going to have to get this.
Hello?
Bethany Bongiorno: Hey, babe.
IC: Hey, Bethany.
How's it going?
BB: Good. Are you at TED?
IC: Yeah, I'm on the red circle
right now, actually.
Bethany: Oh, great, good luck.
And don't forget to mention me.
(Laughter)
IC: I won't, babe, thank you.
Bethany: Love you.
IC: Love you, too. Bye.
It's going to get different in a minute.
(Applause)
So my wife, Bethany,
and our entire company, Humane,
have been working to answer
the question of what comes next.
And you may ask yourself, why?
Why would anybody do this?
It's because we love building technology
that genuinely makes
people's lives better.
And we believe that artificial
intelligence or AI
would be the driving force
behind the next leap in device design.
And there is an incredible amount of stuff
that's happening in this space.
Huge, huge advancements.
And even Bill Gates
has said of OpenAI's GPT
that it's only the second most
revolutionary technology demonstration
that he's seen in his entire lifetime.
But what do we do
with all these incredible developments,
and how do we actually harness these
to genuinely make our life better?
If we get this right,
AI will unlock a world
of possibility for all of us.
And today I want to share with you
what we think is a solution to that end.
And it's the first time
we're doing so openly.
It's a new kind of wearable device
and platform that's built
entirely from the ground up
for artificial intelligence.
And is completely standalone.
You don't need a smartphone
or any other device to pair with it.
In fact, I'm wearing one right now.
And it interacts with the world
the way you interact with the world.
Hearing what you hear,
seeing what you see.
While being privacy-first and safe
and completely fading
into the background of your life.
We like to say that the experience
is screenless, seamless
and sensing,
allowing you to access
the power of compute
while remaining present
in your surroundings,
fixing a balance that's felt
out of place for some time now.
And I can't wait to share more details
about what we've built,
and I will in the next few months.
But today I want to talk to you
about what it unlocks.
And what it means to be able
to take AI with you everywhere.
And what happens when technology
increasingly disappears.
Technology becoming invisible
affords us new opportunities
of how we interact with compute.
We've become so accustomed
to tapping on an app
or moving a cursor with a mouse
that it feels second nature.
But that's by design.
When I was working on the iPhone,
I used to test interactions
like slide-to-unlock
with my infant daughter.
She was the best possible focus group.
She’s 16 now,
and she's got a lot more ideas
than she did back then.
This also, by the way,
is the only non-AI generated image
that you'll see from me today.
And as I look at it now,
I see more than ever
why a future driven by AI
is far better than a future
that would involve more screens.
Like this.
He's cute, though.
But for the human-technology relationship
to actually evolve beyond screens,
we need something radically different.
Let me show you.
Where can I find a gift for my wife
before I have to leave tomorrow?
(Voice) Vancouver's Granville Island
is a lively shopping district.
IC: That's an incredibly simple response
for a very complex query.
How often do we find
ourselves in a new city,
wrestling with our phones,
trying not to bump into people,
trying to figure out where we're going
and where we're supposed to be?
It's even harder when we don't
speak the language, right?
Let me show you something.
Invisible devices should feel
so natural to use
that you almost forget
about their existence.
(Voice speaking in French)
IC: You'll note that's me
and my voice, speaking fluent French,
using an AI speech model
that's part of my own AI.
This is not a deepfake.
In fact, it's deeply profound.
This is my AI giving me the ability
to speak any language
and you having a chance
to hear me speak that language
in my own emotion and my own voice.
Thank you.
(Applause)
This is moving away from the experiments
that make us all concerned
about the direction compute is going in.
But it's instead using technology
to create real, responsible
compute products
that are in service to us
and built on trust.
This is good AI in action.
And we spent thousands of hours
reimagining and redesigning new types
of compute interactions,
ranging from complex voice commands
to intricate hand gestures,
all in service of trying to find more
natural ways to interact with compute.
Why fumble for your phone
when you can just hold an object
and ask questions about it?
The result almost feels like the entire
world becomes your operating system.
And when compute disappears,
it allows us to get back
to what really matters:
a new ability to be present.
Like riding a bicycle in the park
and just ripping through emails
or going to a concert without having
to hold up your phone to capture it.
Or experiencing your toddler's first steps
without a screen
between you and your child.
In the future,
technology will be both
ambient and contextual.
And this means harnessing AI
to really understand you
and your surroundings
in order to achieve the best results.
Imagine this.
You've been in meetings all day
and you just want a summary
of what you've missed.
Catch me up.
(Voice) Patrick is coming
to tomorrow's design meeting.
Bethany wants to move next week's dinner,
and Oliver is asking
about soccer this weekend.
IC: These are emails,
calendar invites and messages,
all surfaced up to the top.
You can use these to help
guide your decision making,
manage your workload
and sculpt tailored responses
in your own voice.
And in the context of your life.
And we gain this context
through machine learning.
The more you use our device powered by AI,
the more we can help you
in all times of need.
Your AI effectively
becomes an ever-evolving,
personalized form of memory.
And we think that's amazing.
In fact, let's say you're health conscious
or you have certain types
of food considerations.
Let me just show you.
Picked up one of these chocolates.
Used to eat a ton of these
when I was a kid.
Can I eat this?
(Voice) A milky bar contains cocoa butter.
Given your intolerance,
you may want to avoid it.
IC: So I can’t eat these anymore.
(Applause)
But what's cool is my AI knows
what's best for me.
But I'm in total control.
I'm going to eat it anyway.
(Laughter)
(Voice) Enjoy it.
IC: Your AI figures out
exactly what you need.
And by the way, I love
that there's no judgment.
I think it's amazing
to be able to live freely.
Your AI figures out what you need
at the speed of thought.
A sense that will ever be evolving
as technology improves too.
And these examples are just the start.
As AI advances,
we will see how it will transform
nearly every aspect of our lives.
In ways that will seem
unimaginable right now.
In fact, Sam Altman from OpenAI
feels the way we do.
And that AI is grossly underestimated.
And I'll add, so long as we get it right.
We really believe
that we're only beginning to scratch
the surface of what's possible.
Embed advancements of AI, like
in our device that's actually
built to disappear
and allow experiences to come forward,
and we open up entirely new possible ways
of how you interact with technology
and how you interact
with the world around you.
More humane, intuitive interactions
that are screenless, seamless and sensing.
This is so much more than devices
just getting smaller or more powerful.
This is the possibility of reimagining
the human-technology relationship
as we know it.
And that's what's so exciting.
It's a huge challenge, no doubt.
But it's the world
that we want to live in.
One where technology not only helps you
get back into the world
but enhances our ability to do so.
It's within reach.
And you saw some of it today.
The future will not be held in your hand,
and it won't be on your face either.
The future of technology
might almost be invisible.
Thank you.
(Applause)